[music playing]
I was being asked to
be John Gotti's hit man.
If I refused, John
Gotti would kill me.
I understood that.
The key part of my plan
was to get Georgie Grasso
drunk on drugs to keep
him loose so there
was no problem killing him.
I'm at the bar, and
Georgie Grasso walks in.
I go, hey, Georgie.
Come on.
Come over.
We're all having shots.
And he goes, ah, just one.
I'm going to leave early.
I told him, just have one shot.
It ain't going to kill you.
Have a shot.
And once he puts down the first
one, inside me, I say, OK.
I got him.
Once I have Georgie
drunk and high,
he's going to want to
continue the partying.
And I tell Georgie, go shotgun.
I sit right behind
Georgie Grasso's seat,
because from there,
I'm going to choose
where I think is comfortable
to shoot him in the head.
We're driving down
this quiet road.
And he's laughing,
and I'm laughing.
As we're having that
banter, somewhere
in the back of your
conscience, you're saying,
am I going to do this, really?
Am I going to take
this guy's life?
And the other side of me
is saying, you promised.
You don't obey this
order, somebody I trust
is going to kill me, too.
And I'm nervous.
Can I really do this?
I put one into the chamber.
Do it.
[radio chatter]
Don't do it.
Just do it.
He's going to get killed
one way or another.
I'm not getting
killed for this guy.
I finally picked up the gun.
I stuck it around the headrest.
And I just--
[gunshot]
Nobody said anything.
It kind of really hit me.
Wow, this guy's gone.
I really killed this guy.
As I look back on it,
that was the biggest
mistake I ever made in my life.
You just killed yourself
with that bullet.
Although you're
not in the ground,
you just destroyed your life.